foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
up here's Morgan uncensored tonight
female footballers make fresh demands
for Equal Pay ahead of the Women's World
Cup is it time for sport to pay its
female Talent fairly or do men still
earn their advantage will have that
thorny debate also tonight former
president Trump this is a third criminal
indictment this time over the January
6th riots Governor Aza Hutchinson one of
his Rivals as Republican candidate for
president demands that Trump now
suspends his campaign and joins me live
plus a controversial barge for housing
refugees as docked in Britain as
officials order children's murals to be
struck from the walls for a Detention
Center the UK has to solve this migrant
crisis but are we forgetting our
Humanity or debate
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening from London welcome to Pearson
organized Center many of the stereotypes
about Millennials almost as lazy as some
of them are they like avocados on toast
they take photos of avocados on toast
bad tattoos skinny jeans dating apps
cats you get the picture and censorship
of course like a lot of stereotypes they
begin life with a kernel of Truth a
major survey in the U.S found that a
plurality of people aged 25 to 34 now I
think using the wrong pronouns should be
a criminal offense almost half of them
think you should be prosecuted for
saying he instead of she if that he is
becoming a she or if he or she just
wants to be they or thinks they should
be a she he they or something like a cat
you could be forgiven for being as
confused about this as some of them are
and that's the point most decent people
have no real problem with referring to
trans people by their chosen gender I
try and do it myself if nothing else is
just polite and good manners but most
decent people also find all this
completely baffling stop somewhere in
the streets of Barnsley or Baltimore and
ask them for their personal preferred
pronouns they'll ask you what the hell
you're talking about look what happened
when CNN the very Paragons of virtue
signaling analyze the disastrous impact
that trans influence of Dylan Mulvaney
who until last year identified as a gay
man uh had on sales of Bud Light
they don't like the way Delvin Mulvaney
was treated after this whole controversy
started he courses the transgender uh
person they were going to uh sponsor and
go along with with Bud Light they didn't
like how Bud Light didn't stand by him
him oh dear
but he wasn't him last year but not
anymore and the next day CNN where I
used to work full of fine people all
very well intentioned had to issue a
groveling apology
before we wrap up today we do want to
make an important note yesterday in a
segment about transgender influencer
Dylan Mulvaney who was featured in Bud
light's recent campaign she was
mistakenly referred to by the wrong
pronoun and CNN aims to honor
individuals ways of identifying
themselves and we apologize for that
error
I mean really execution is too good for
that but you see that's how difficult it
all is isn't it should CNN journalist
now be jailed for that obvious hate
crime
and criminal offense or not the tyranny
of the pronoun police is all around us
misgendering can get you kicked off
YouTube which for some people has
removed there's some main source of
income it briefly led to the what is a
woman documentary by Matt Walsh being
banned on Twitter and Oxford College
just warned it will expel students for
misgendering each other the UK
government's long-winded guidance for
schools on trans-pupils has today been
delayed reportedly because of legal
wrangling over whether teachers must use
a student's preferred pronouns many
businesses now require their staff to
wear pronoun badges or sign off their
emails with their pronouns and if you
accept all of that criminalization
probably looks like The Logical Next
Step yeah sling the miscreants in prison
now in my view what should actually be
illegal if you're going to get into
gender criminality might be the idea of
biological men destroying women born
with biological female bodies in women's
sport that's a bit of a crime to me or
biological men demanding access to
female changing rooms full of biological
females many of them grow young
or biological male rapists who identify
as women at their trials to get into
women's prisons
maybe that should be a crime and if you
think that makes me a transphobe I'd say
you're the one with the phobia of Common
Sense
well join him in the studio socialist
and author Grace Blakely and YouTube
commentator Paul Davis uh both I would
imagine identifying as provocateurs of
course
[Laughter]
first of all Paul
I just find
the whole personal pronoun thing
honestly absurd my personal pronouns on
my Twitter biography are now uh hot
hotter hottest and frankly if people
don't call me those then they have to be
jailed I go along with that but I did
that to highlight that when I do that
and say that people then accuse me of
being ridiculous I think the whole thing
is ridiculous why do we need personal
pronouns we don't need personal pronouns
I honestly I don't think it's kind to
allow people to live in delusion wait at
the end of the day at the end of the day
at the end of the day
we all know
all the black woman is okay just because
you dress like a woman talk like a woman
act like a woman it does not make you a
woman and I am so tired of us allowing
these people to let us live in delusion
it is delusional to think you are the
opposite gender and it is not kind I
can't even go on I love flying British
Airways right my preferred Airline a
wonderful Airline
and they always used to always be a
lovely Posh voice saying good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen welcome to pretty
and I used to felt soothing particularly
if I came from another country back to
Britain I felt immediately at ease my
captain was there sounding like he was
you know from some wonderful pathy News
Bulletin and he referred to us as ladies
and gentlemen that's now been banned
they're not allowed to say ladies and
gentlemen because there might be one
person on the plane who says oh whoa
whoa hang on I don't identify as a lady
or a gentleman well okay fine I don't
care but I do so where's my right to be
called a gentleman here's Grace I know
how I feel up with this I'm so so bored
of it all I'm so bored of the fact that
this is the one item that's constantly
coming up over and over and over again
and you can completely see why right
conservative governments have destroyed
our economy we're in the middle of a
massive climate crisis just after the
hottest week ever I've just come over
from Europe it's extremely hot and
instead of talking about that we spend
hours and hours and hours talking about
pronouns talking about going into
bathrooms talking about you know all of
this stuff that just doesn't matter it
doesn't matter hang on hang on doesn't
matter to you so boring doesn't matter
to you but it does matter to women in
sport it does matter to women whose
young daughters might be using these
dressings it doesn't matter to the
victims of male rapists who see their
attackers identify as women get into
women's prisons sorry so when you say
they don't matter they really do matter
you have those issues aired in the
appropriate you know spaces we are in
you know in sports have that discussion
amongst people but like literally it's
about priorities isn't it there is a
certain number of times we have on these
shows to discuss the issues
you don't think women's before we come
to our I don't think women's sport
matters as much as climate change I
think like it's women's equality in
which we can play sports women's
equality I know that it could be
probably absolutely quality mattity well
I mean yeah of course but actually I
mean the whole point that I was going to
make on this segment actually is that
like you cannot separate feminism from
class issues like if you're just going
around saying like I don't know
um I think the female CEO of a weapons
manufacturer should be paid the same as
a male CEO and that's the hill I'm gonna
die on I'm not fighting that fight with
you because ultimately like what I care
about are the struggles that ordinary
women face every day well let's come to
the the main point of the segment which
is this issue of women's rights to be
paid the same as men in sport now the
Australian women's football team have
criticized the pay Gap in the upcoming
World Cup prize money just take a look
at what was they said as a team
736 footballers had the honor of
representing their country on the
world's biggest stage this tournament
yeah many are still denied the basic
right to organize and collectively
bargain collective bargaining has
allowed us to ensure we now get the same
conditions as the socceroos with one
exception FIFA will still only offer
women one quarter as much prize money as
men for the same achievement
well okay this is an interesting part
because if you look at the revenue for
example in 2019 FIFA generated uh 586
million pounds in total revenue the
men's uh for the 19 2019-22 cycle 5.8
billion uh record Revenue through the
men's World Cup so the women's game has
come on in Leaps and Bounds the English
lionesses fantastic win sellout crowds
they're making a lot more money they're
definitely way way further now towards
whether men are commercially than they
were but they're still a way off and
when you saw at Wimbledon for example
the men's final was watched by three
times as many people and yet they were
both free to wear on the BBC you can
watch both if you wanted to so there was
three times as much interest in the
men's game they played two sets more per
match than the women doing it the women
get equal pay I'm not quite sure why I
don't think it's a matter of equality
it's just a matter of fairness isn't it
yeah well I I won I think all of the
women should thank the men for fun
ending our leagues because most of our
leagues would not exist without the men
number one number two when we have the
same numbers then we should get the same
pay I'm sorry I play I play volleyball
at the highest level and it's like when
we make what the men make and get the
crowds that the men draw then we should
get paid the same why why is it actually
a fight for equality Grace I mean why if
if women in a particular sport for
example turned out to generate more
Revenue right because they were more
watchable and in America the women's
football team is better than the men and
they do generate even a school level far
more interest from girls than boys for
example I don't see why equality should
be the aim why shouldn't they get paid
more than the men well look I mean there
are all sorts of problems with the way
that this market for labor and it is
basically a market for labor works like
I personally don't think that the top
football players in the world should be
paid as much as they do I think it's
ridiculous the amount that's marketing
exactly it's Market forces that be the
way that we decide you know who's to
generate what who generates more
personally I'm very much in favor of the
fact that they came out there and said
collective bargaining ultimately like at
the average worker in this country
hasn't had a pay rise in over a decade
how is that going to change that's going
to change when they organize with one
another I'm tired of women whining their
names the men literally the men fund our
leagues and we will still whine that we
don't get paid enough and honestly when
athletes do like this it makes all
of us look bad because instead of being
thankful for the league that we have we
go out and whine and complain about the
pay I mean as I said I'm not whining you
sound like you're maybe doing a bit of
whining but like personally I don't
think we should be whining I think
people should be organized
join a union get out there and fight for
it should the women footballers get the
same as the men yeah I think it probably
makes sense even if anything like the
revenue ultimately like it's not gonna
change it's not going to change unless
they organize that's actually true
across every sector
let me ask you this it on Talent alone
for example as a yardstick the U.S
women's football team were beaten by a
group of under 15 boys from Texas right
who were very good under 15 boys but
they're under 15 boys team beat them I
think about eight nine nil or something
so why should women footballers who are
clearly nowhere near as good as their
male counterparts just technically why
should they get paid anything like as
much money well I mean you know
you know you're you play volleyball I'm
a surfer absolutely love surfing it's
very hard for women to build up a body
strength this is something that I've
learned that very much the hard way and
so so by the way there is there is equal
pay yeah there is and actually you know
it it's one of those Sports where can a
woman be as good as a man well it's
different it's a different sport really
it's not you know it is the same sport
but it's very different watching women's
love than is watching amanza because you
know the average male body is different
from the average woman like uh woman's
body for all this but is there any
actual technical reason why a woman
can't do with a circle what a man can do
yeah there's I mean there's loads of
reasons like it is about the upper body
strength it's about like the way that
the body is built should women Surfers
at the elite level get the same as me
like again I think it's it just is
different like it's a different kind of
game and people watch it oh you're
shaking your head no I just think when
we start making the same amount of money
as the man then we should get paid the
same as the man I don't hear the man
whining about only fans models getting
paid more than them I don't hear the men
whining about models getting paid more
than that Kendall Jenner is the highest
paid supermodel where are the male super
models however men dominated in Industry
women will just complain I mean I don't
know if that's true about any fans
because there are a lot of men on only
fans as well but I mean look the main
point I think they make the same I have
no idea but like maybe if you average
out the number of men and women that are
on that website anyway look the main
point here the point that I came on it I
wanted to make was the um the like the
problem that we have in in our economy
at the moment is not that like the
average football player isn't played the
same as the average man it is probably
an injustice and I'm glad that they're
organizing and working together to fight
for that but ultimately the problem we
have in our economy is that nobody's
getting paid enough money because
inflation's eroded people's wages even
before that no one had a pay rise in a
really long time and the lesson from
this is as I've said I'm going to say it
again because it's an important lesson
and no one knows about them anymore
because they see them as a hangover from
1970s join a union because otherwise
your boss is going to work well there
are unions for all these they're all
it's a unions that are finding for them
exactly but okay but just as a general
point though
the principle you think that women
should get paid the same even if they're
not as technically as good and not
producing as much revenue objective
judgment isn't it on whether or not
they're like technically
Let me Give an example an example would
be the Olympics if you made it
non-gender specific how many women would
win medals well I mean no okay there may
be an equestrian and maybe in shooting I
think again there's no sense that the
men might win you can say like oh you
know this group is better than this
group but again I think it's different
men are better than women what sports
yes let's not live in this delusion and
in most cases
more people men and women want to watch
men play sports correct that's just a
demonstrable fact that may change so my
point is if it changes I don't see why
equality should be the only ambition for
the women if it turns out that in some
sport women get more viewers watching
and therefore draw more Revenue I'm more
for them getting more money than the men
can you name five WNBA players five
female soccer players I mean I can't
name any soccer players
we would get equal pay if we would just
get the support from the family well let
me tell you let me tell you name five
but I do want to mention one thing which
is I had Dale Vince on the program he's
this uh he's been funding just stop oil
and also he was very very keen to show
his feminist credentials because he just
he owns a football team and he had just
hired the first female manager of a
football team but there was a slight
problem which he only made of the
caretaker and I saw a potential flaw
here so let's see what went down when I
interviewed him
you didn't think by pointing the first
female caretaker manager of a
professional men's team you would get
any attention
she's the best candidate for the job at
the club this is what happens you look
at within the club you find your best
coach and you say take the team in an
interim period while we do a proper
recruitment process that's always
Happening Here how do you keep coming
back to that
of appointments she's only a caretaker
look at our record so if you believed
him that much yeah you've got all the
publicity but actually she's not got the
full result yeah it works and I suspect
what's going to happen is football
you're going to probably go and find a
bloke to replace her and then you're
going to have to deal with that I
I thought you understood football piss I
don't think
well you might be massively unsurprised
to learn that 12 Days Later
Anna Dinkley has been removed from her
job as caretaker manager and replaced by
a man
yeah Dale talk to good game on feminism
and women's rights and posted about it
and got all the publicity and in the end
he got rid of her after 12 days and put
a broke in charge and you can make your
own view about Mr Vince for doing that
uh lovely to see you both thank you both
very much indeed on sensitive next
former president Trump says he expects
to be arrested again by a federal
inquiry into U.S capital riots on
January 6 last year Republican Governor
Asia Hutchinson who is running as
Republican candidate to be president
says that Trump must now suspend his
campaign he joins me next live
live
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to your peers welcome
downstairs and former president Donald
Trump says he expects to be arrested and
indicted again this time by federal
inquiry into the capital riots and
efforts to overturn the 2020 election
Trump posted on his truth social
platform that it was a scam and a hoax
saying deranged Jack Smith the
prosecutor with Joe Biden's doj send a
letter stating that I'm a target of the
January 6th grand jury investigation and
giving me a very short four days report
to the grand jury which almost always
means an arrest and indictment where
former Arkansas governor Aza Hutchinson
who is running against Trump for the
Republican nominations call for him to
suspend his campaign say anyone who
truly loves this country and is willing
to put the country over themselves would
suspend their campaign for president of
the United States immediately it is
disappointing that Donald Trump refuses
to do so neither Hutchinson joins me now
uh welcome to you Governor um it does
seem quite extraordinary I have to say
particularly now I've come back over
this side of the pond having been in
America last week people are incredulous
here that a presidential candidate
already facing
serious criminal charges is now
potentially about to face yet more in an
attempt to thwart the result of a
democratic election and could
potentially after that face another raft
in relation to phone calls he made in in
Georgia
um how is this happening
well first of all it's not a happy day
for America this is not a good
representation of our democracy and how
did it happen it happened because of
Donald Trump's irresponsibility and
potential criminal conduct I've said all
along that he was morally responsible
for January 6 and what happened in the
attack of the capital but now Jack Smith
a special prosecutor is through the
grand jury saying he's criminally
responsible as well that has to be
tested through the courts but my point
is that this is a incredible distraction
from all the issues that we face as a
nation it's a distraction for the
campaign it's a distraction to Donald
Trump and if you put your country first
then you just step aside because this is
too much for the country and for him and
for everyone to deal with during this
critical time in our country and that's
what I mean I've been a federal
prosecutor I know what's at stake here
when you've got two pending indictments
and you've got another one that's coming
this is not going to be a pretty sight
for the next 60 next next six months
here's the problem I think that you have
certainly as a republican candidate but
that America also has I guess
democratically which is that Trump each
time he gets indicted simply goes on the
attack and he's doing it again here
before he's actually been formally
indicted but it's almost certain that he
will be you know he basically turns into
a political thing he says that it's a
third indictment and it's the arrest of
Joe Biden's number one political
opponent himself who is largely
dominating him in the race of the
presidency well he's way ahead in the
polls and each time one of these things
happens Trump's popularity in the poll
seems to go up not down which is also
extraordinary what can you as a
republican candidate trying to make him
suspend his his campaign which he I
don't think he will for a moment what
can you do to stop the Trump machine
from just barreling through all this
given that his own supporters his own
base simply don't seem to care
well you're right to appears that he's
very likely to go up in the polls get a
bump from this because of the indictment
and there's a perception that this is
politically motivated in some way and of
course who drives that that's driven by
Donald Trump and uh what's happening
here is that he's not talking about the
pop the facts he's talking about the
politics of it and so you know if this
is going to change voters thinking it's
going to be over the course of time when
they realize that the Republican party
can't win with Donald Trump as the
nominee with all of these external
pressures you can't attract Independence
you can't attract Suburban voters so
we're going to lose and so that has to
be absorbed and then secondly the
seriousness of the allegations I can't
speak to the January 6th because I don't
know what he's going to charge but
whenever you look at the mishandling of
classified information these are our
nation's secrets and for a former
president to use those with
entertainment value these are important
facts action whether they're brought out
in terms of the court case I'll
certainly be bringing them out in terms
of the campaign because they're relevant
what kind of Commander to Chief are we
going to have you as you say the federal
prosecutor when you saw what was laid
out in the charges just for the
documents alone obviously the Stormy
Daniels thing I think is a a smaller
Affair legally but the stolen documents
when you read the child sheet there how
serious do you think it is and How
likely is it that he could be convicted
well those charges are as serious they
get in the criminal case context Jack
Smith laid out the facts very clearly I
recognize that there's always a
different side of this as presented in
court but it doesn't get any more
serious particularly for someone who
wants to be our commander-in-chief again
there's a presumption of innocence it's
going to be tried in court but this is
serious and the allegations on January 6
are serious now they're particularly
serious on the the body politic the
entire voting base the Republican party
needs to wake up and say we can't have
someone who opposes a peaceful transfer
of power under our democracy and that's
exactly what happened and the question
that Jack Smith has got to prove did he
know that at the time he summoned
everyone to the Capitol and wanted them
to oppose the transfer of power which
caused them to march on the capitol what
do you know at that time yeah again what
I would say though here is the problem
politically is it doesn't stop him if
he's indicted multiple times from
running as a candidate the Constitution
allows that it doesn't stop him even if
he's convicted even if he's sent to
prison Donald Trump could continue to
not only run as a candidate be actually
be president now it would be completely
unprecedented but most things trumpian
are so how do you look you're currently
polling at one percent yourself in the
race he's over 50 in many of the polls
he's so far ahead of everybody all these
indictments seem to do as I say seem to
help him they seem to pump up his
numbers Kevin McCarthy was saying that
today
um I just don't know how you can stop
him winning the nomination and he would
then think Trump I know him very well in
a two-horse race against Joe Biden who
looks like he's barely functioning and
we're still 18 months away from an
election he'd have a very good chance of
winning
well that's the only hope that Joe Biden
would have would be if Donald Trump is
on the other side indicted not being
able to pull independent votes and that
was the what we had in 2020 when he
wasn't under indictment and he lost he
lost that race and lots happened since
then you ask what's going to change it I
don't know but I know that as a
candidate who cares about this country
you don't sit on the sideline when our
democracy is at stake whenever our
country is at stake I'm engaged in this
fight we got six months before the Iowa
caucuses and I know that Iowa's looking
at this and potentially looking for an
alternative the the other candidates
were in mostly single digits it's going
to be whose surface is out of that and
who takes on Trump uh straight on and I
think you've got to do that if you're
running for president in the Republican
primary there are two clips I want to
play one is Donald Trump when he talks
about what he could get away with
because of his popularity and he talked
about shooting someone on Fifth Avenues
take a look
they say I have the most loyal people
did you ever see that where I could
stand in the middle of Fifth Avenue and
shoot somebody and I wouldn't lose any
voters okay it's like incredible
now he was presumably joking but
actually he's probably right now it
would look like he could almost
certainly do what he said there and he
wouldn't move the needle at all uh
secondly I want to play a clip because
of you being booed at the Turning Point
action conference yesterday let's take a
look at this
[Applause]
[Music]
so the two things that one I think he's
reached that point we can basically do
what he likes and his base isn't going
to we'll just listen to his explanation
and believe it but secondly for you as a
conservative a long time Republican who
really cares about his party in his
country to get that kind of response at
a conservative event
um how did you feel about that and what
does that tell you about where the party
now is
well on the first clip that you played
what that tells you about Donald Trump
is that he's full of arrogance I think
everybody knows that and whenever I
think about public service I think more
about humility and serving the public
versus selving your serving your own
interest the second clip that you played
was me speaking really at a pro-trump
gathering and I go to that audience
because I know they're not all aligned
with me by any means but I make the case
of a conservative vision for America and
where we need to go you've got to reach
out to those audiences thank goodness
there were a lot of young people there
thousands of them who were very
interested despite some bad leadership
and behavior on the part of some of the
adults in the room if Donald Trump is
watching this he probably is
um what would you say to him
well I would say step aside for the good
of the country you're not going to be
able to successfully win you know that
just like you knew that you lost in
2020. so think this through I hope that
you'll make that decision and drop out
for the good of the country you know the
problem uh Aza Hutchinson is that that's
exactly what so many people told him in
2016. I remember everyone said you
haven't got a chance drop out and he
just barreled on and he won the
presidency and I'm sure part of him is
thinking if Biden's the opponent I've
got every chance
good point and that's why if you're
going to win the nomination it's got to
go through Donald Trump we got to take
it in the debates we got to take it on
the campaign Trail and win
Governor great to talk to you thanks for
appearing on the show I appreciate it
thank you pierce well it says the next a
barge like into a floating prison docks
in Britain it'll house 500 male Asylum
Seekers is it a deterrent or is
Britain's migrant policy becoming
increasingly inhumane we'll debate that
next
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
set to accommodate 500 Asylum Seekers
has been likened to a quasi prison and
is now docked in Dorset the arrival of
the controversial vessel comes hours
after the government's illegal migration
bill passed the Lords the prime
minister's spokesperson has defended the
use of barges to house migrants
assisting it's a cheaper alternative to
accommodating them in hotels I'm joined
now by the political journalist Ava
Santino a talk to you presenter Richard
sice okay Richard
barges for assignancies when you look at
it it does look like a floating prison
are you comfortable will that sound
completely comfortable because this
barge has been used as an accommodation
barge for 30 years
twice it's been used in different
countries for Asylum Seekers It's been
used for construction workers for
offshore wind farms it's been used in
Shetland in Scotland for the
construction workers for a gas plant I
don't recall hearing Alex salmond or
Nicholas sturgeon complaining back then
when it was working towards their
economy this is a sensible such a
ridiculous false equivalent it's not a
false equivalent it's exactly right it's
been used by construction workers over
there by choice
we know that many of these are economic
migrants and they made the choice to
come here over so that completely
disappeared
no because so why is it why is it why is
it why is it appropriate for
construction workers but not appropriate
for people who've come across the
English especially they were they were
there by choice and secondly the reason
these people have come here by their own
choice they could have stayed in for the
safe country to use this barge is
because it looks intimidating and it
looks unappealing yes it's been used as
an accommodation barge for 30 years
I'm going to make an offer why don't we
suggest so they I'll go down to the bar
here's my response
they've doubled the number of people on
the bus to what it's normally housing so
that's that's a fact that's actually not
true it's not true no that's not true
I'm told that it's true well I'm told
that it's not true it's been used
apparently they've doubled it for the
Asylum Seekers yes and twice as many
people on it but it was originally used
Asylum seekers in the Netherlands and
elsewhere with the same sort of number
this is its maximum we don't know that I
do know that because I checked it up
today I don't here's my offer let's go
down jointly let's go and stay for a
couple of nights and see what it's like
a good idea I'll tell you what we could
love live using their good Wi-Fi we
could come on your show that's a great
idea I'm not gonna go and torment people
who have already questions about
learning the facts these are people
we're talking about people who fleed war
and persecution and we're talking about
them as they're just sort of objects and
movables okay this isn't a problem
they're not all legitimate Asylum
Seekers yeah we know that last year for
example of the people that came on the
boats about a third were economic
migrants from Albania they weren't
actually from war-torn countries at all
so that's not statistically true let me
speak to that for one moment why isn't
the home office employing more people to
process Asylum Seekers people who come
over with claims why what I agree with
you at the moment what they're doing
they're just processing them very slow
because they're incompetent and woeful
like we're agreed but we also have this
issue with this this hotel for example
in Westworld and so Earthly the strady
Park Hotel where apparently they're
basically made 100 staff redundant
they're going to put the whole place
taken over by Asylum Seekers and local
residents had gone completely nuts about
this and I can understand why they'd be
concerned about that that can't be right
either putting them up in four-star
hotels at our expense grapes with people
right putting them on the barge might
great with you but you've got to do
something with them until they sort out
the processing they'll explain to me
something Pierce all right there's
double the amount of people that should
be on that bar you know okay all right
well we'll ignore that premise for a
moment what if something breaks it
you've got to let me make up the barge's
capacity is going to be increased from
222 to 500. there were 222 rooms and you
can have it as single beds or as double
but they're actually dusters they're
double link the capacity for people and
let me talk to you about what happened
in manston all right what broke out in
manston don't do a bit of water should
we focus on the barge influence it was
where we were until we sort out the
processing centers which has to be done
what where are you going to put all
these people you need to process them
that's what you need where are you going
to put them so you want tents in armored
barracks if you treated this like an
emergency War situation and you actually
process people correctly you wouldn't
have to you know bring in barges to
house them or bring in new how are you
going to deter the people Smugglers and
all the people who are just trying it on
as economic migrants how do you sift
through all that and get to legitimate
and I agree with you we have to be
Humane about Asylum Seekers and
legitimate refugees from war-torn
countries not least some countries where
we've started the wars or engaged in
them if they were fought illegally like
Iraq so you have to sell me on that but
my issue I think is on behalf of
everybody else who's concerned about
this is that you've got to do something
about all these people coming where do
you physically put them and put them in
four-star hotels it's causing a lot of
social unrest you can't have that the
processing isn't up to speed yet the
barge all right you can say it looks
like a president yeah it looks a bit
like a cheap cruise ship actually is it
that bad to put them there and process
things and tell me why we won't put a
processing center in Calais that was
suggested by macron years ago we put a
processing center there then no one
makes that that dangerous trip over
we're agreed I've been suggesting that
for months and months and months but
look hear me out that barge it's used
for construction workers but according
to you it's not good enough for Asylum
Seekers I was down until yesterday let
me tell you the good people of fluent
athlete they have blocked the access to
that hotel it's on unregistered land the
neighbors deny the access to it they've
got tents now they're staying overnight
they're not going to let that be used
they are saying enough
who lives in that area he says there's
absolute Mayhem down there because they
just think it's completely wrong and I
got a lot of symptoms it's the main
Hotel the main conference and spa hotel
for the whole of the Earthly and the
surrounding that cannot be right over
but what I don't understand is why there
is the sort of categorization of people
why you think that people who are
fleeing war in persecution
are not supposed to be staying in that
hotel somehow for some reason other
people so you don't care about the
hundreds of these Community residents
who've been made redundant why are they
better people because they're better
citizens most of those people have come
here illegally
they've come here
talking to the good residents of film
who are absolutely steaming Fury tell
you what the other thing people are
steamed and Furious about going to a
yougov poll released today 63 to britons
like I said a brexit to be more of a
failure than a success just 12 of those
RC brexit is more of a success and
failure that's unbelievable I mean that
is heading to the point where it's not
unbelievable because what it is is a
reflection of fact that most people
recognize that this government hasn't
taken advantage of the opportunity if
you talk to brexiteers who voted for
brexit they don't regret the vote what
their distance
migration of 600 000 people uh we're now
appealing for construction workers to
come into the country from other
countries even though we've got five
minutes the boats continue to be out of
control
the loudest claim of the brexiters that
somehow we would be controlling our
borders it's obviously complete nonsense
because the government have completely
failed to do it because I'm not in
charge
they've been trying everything but
brexit they haven't tried everything
they deliberately created they did
deliberately it's right a low skill open
borders at what point do you accept
brexit as a word I'd say that somebody
by the way a voted remain but I then
stuck my neck out and said I absolutely
on the result the referendum I attack
the ramonas who didn't I said democracy
depends on accepting the results of
these votes but I think the argument not
to have another vote if that number of
bridges we've only left two and a half
years in 2016. yeah but we've only let
peers we've only left
years ago it appears don't be
disingenuous we left it in trade terms
at the end of 2020. I tell you what if I
was in charge it would be a great
success frankly no because you didn't
have a trading agreement with the
largest trading we've got a trade
agreement with the largest trading block
we've just signed another one with an
even bigger Trading Zone in Asia the
fastest growing trading service like
talking it's like there's no point in
speaking because obviously you know that
exporters are now facing all of this red
tape they're fighting to get their
products into Europe and they're paying
extortionate fees to do it you know that
business well you don't know because you
haven't done the research is that our
trade figures we're actually exporting
more in value terms than we were at the
end of 16 or at the end of 2020 you
don't know that because you haven't done
the research but you know what Richard
the truth is that reflects my own
anecdotal chats with people and it's not
that they feel that they were betrayed
or lied to any of those things which the
ramonas love to say although there's
some argument I think on both sides were
disingenuous it's just they just feel
not working and they feel that after a
pandemic and a financial crisis and a
war in Newbury the last thing we need is
to be pouring fuel on our own wounds and
they feel that's what we're doing my
question is at what point
does brexit need to work to justify not
having another referendum what the
government of the day who who fought for
this as I did but I'm not the government
of the day they've got to do they've got
to take advantage of the opportunities
oh you've got to get rid of the dark
regulations you've got to cut government
waste and cut taxes for people and
you've got to go through it and you've
got to control your borders
but why did Boris Johnson the man who
led the brexit charge why didn't he do
all this very good question get him in
here and ask him because he hasn't done
it the Tory government the tour is the
tourism election on the back of getting
brexit done and they haven't done it
because
they're all done and dust it was all
easy that's turned out to be a total
disaster would be a total disaster peers
let's just remember the Eurozone is in
recession so I don't know why everybody
seems to think they're a massive success
story like over Germany is in recession
we're gonna have another referendum Tony
Blair thinks it's too late and they're
basically the damage is done and to go
back in is too painful I I think it's
too you might be right question but I
mean obviously I mean clearly this isn't
working I mean clearly we need to have
some kind of access to the market in
Europe it's absolute I would just like
just just just clarify right the
Eurozone is in recession we're not so
we're actually doing better analysts do
say that we are in recession we just
haven't done we might be heading out
towards one I've got a timeout we run
out of time uh the debate will continue
until or if brexit works I'm holding my
breath Richard sorry mate I'm not
holding my breath we'll if I'm in charge
uh good to see you but will you make it
you have to get elected first correct
that's what I'm planning to do well good
luck if you do come back on the show and
so I said next tonight I'll do Carl
steffanovic and the rest of the
Australian media call me a big crybaby
and the king of the pony whinges
following the disgraceful treacherous on
sportsmanlike Behavior we witnessing
Australians at Lords in the ashes
earlier this month I thought it was time
to go head to head with the cocky Today
Show host that's next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
coming up on the talk the government's
illegal migration bill will become law
but the arrival of a controversial barge
to house Asylum Seekers triggers
protests and BBC bosses are forced to
face the music over the Hugh Edwards
Scandal and there's Commonwealth Games
chaos as Australia pulls out of hosting
the event that's all at nine
please
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook nonsense that
took a bold stand against the unsporting
treachery Australia's triggers at laws
earlier this month in the ashes and in
turn the Australian media took a bowl
stand against me the Australian
Telegraph newspaper dressed me Ben
Stokes to Jeffrey boycott and Rishi
sunac as giant babies with the headline
a wobbly lower lip Suki Palms keep
spitting the dummy it wasn't just the
papers Carl stefanovic a TV presenter
who is flatteringly for him known as the
Australian Piers Morgan said this on the
big breakfast show over there
Pierce has said that he will come on our
show
when England win the series 3-2 he's
such a lightweight he's a lightweight oh
he's perfect absolutely dreamy expected
oh I can't believe it what a loser
what a loser he didn't stop there he
asked Australian prime minister Anthony
albanazi to ban me from the country
is it time to revoke the Visas of
English Elites like Pierce Morgan that
would be a very harsh measure uh Carl
what what it might be better to do is to
allow people like Pierce Morgan to come
in and to come on your show and remind
him of Australia's massive ashes victory
yeah you won nothing yet prime minister
we're going to win the ashes and ahead
of the Do or Die fourth test match at
all traffic the Stars tomorrow I decided
it was time for me to confront Mr
stefanovic one on one
well I'm joined Now by Carl stefanovic
says Carl you'll be giving it the big
one uh for the last few weeks but you've
gone very very quiet since we rolled you
over in the last test match is that
nerves
basically uh Pierce you know how it is
uh down under we don't really worry
about things until the the very last
minute we've been Gathering the troops
at The Fray and we've been getting our
little toys out of our kids cart so that
we can send them over to you this is a
one of the Native bilbys that you'll be
you'll be sent in the next couple of
days in the lead up to the test that you
can throw them out of your cot with your
dummies when Australia starts to pound
you on day one we are very fired up
about this but in a very quiet way
obviously we wake up like this Pierce
preparation handsome delicious
Australians I know that upsets you
greatly I know that makes you cranky but
this is how we wake up in preparation
for a big test quiet and handsome
actually you look as Haggard drawn and
old as I used to when I do breakfast
television and thank God I'm now in
Prime in Prime Time words you can only
dream about which is why I look by
comparison so youthful and dynamic
youthful and dynamic actually I will say
this you have you have looked better
after that that last victory I know how
concerned you were about it and that's
why we gifted you one test match I mean
can you imagine what would have happened
in your country if Australia had won
that one you would have been crying in
the streets the GDP would have gone down
you would have had to replace your prime
minister the toothpick with eyes as we
call him over here in Australia with
another prime minister there would have
been absolute Mayhem so we've gifted you
to this one we're giving you an
opportunity to get back into the series
Because deep down even though you sent
the worst of us to Australia decades
hundreds of years ago we're back here
for you and we still kind of like you
yeah you know what when we sent all the
convicts to Australia I never dreamed
for a moment that they were the people
they would be still as undesirable as
they were when we sent them but there
you are
undesirable look at this who's the
person you want to have lunch with
whenever you come to Australia and you
want me to pay come on people let me ask
you this look it's good Let's Get
Serious in one moment obviously
obviously your Australian team cheated
with sandpaper gate you cheated again
when Trevor Chapel bowled underarm you
cheated again with the best though uh
Fiasco can you give any undertakings at
all on behalf of your country in the
last two test matches you may at least
trying to buy by the laws and spirit of
the game
look I think this is why we've we've
come to know you as the king of the
Wingers here in Australia and some of us
do love you but effectively what we've
done is having been the worst of us sent
out from the worst and the best of us
sent out from your beautiful country
many many decades hundreds of years ago
we've basically used you get upset
because we use your rules to beat you
um that's that's as effective as I can
be this morning in my message to you so
we will use any rules and twist them
back on the Old Dart because that's
called progress you guys are stuck in
the 60s and the 50s and we're
progressing as a nation let me tell you
let me tell you just to wrap this we're
gonna win the next test at Old Trafford
we're going to go to the oval we're
going to basketball you to within one
inch of your lives and then I'm going to
come on your show and I'm going to do
the greatest gloating segment in the
history of Breakfast Television and
you're going to be physically vomiting
live on air as I show you the ashes and
kiss them after the greatest comeback
since Lazarus and on that bombshell tile
stefanovic as you call yourself over
there stefanovich to your friends in
Europe I will bid you farewell until we
win
all right I'll see you soon and if you
if you win this next test match I'll
come to London and we'll do it in person
and you can buy me a massive lunch I'll
look forward to it take care Carl dad
all right love you mate bye so think
about Australians I do I love them I
love the country I love the culture but
when it comes to Cricket they are
utterly unbearable and yes I do know the
show airs on Sky News Australia so good
evening good evening Thomas
um but I think we're gonna win and when
we do I'm gonna see Mr stefanovic that's
it for tonight come on England bring
back that um you can do it Captain
Stokes good night keep it uncensored
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign